knows everything I'm saying it's simple
you don't have to be scholarship
understand what we're saying if Jesus Is
God you must know everything correct
yeah if it's God but in the Bible Jesus
is another hour
[Laughter]
but God has no good so there's many
things in the Bible I'm not denying by
the way there is some passages that you
can get say yeah Jesus claimed Infinity
but there's many clear passage passages
in the Bible
no I don't believe just they died I
believe Allah praise God Jesus by
protecting him from the death I don't
believe you it does even in your Bible I
don't know if you know about Hebrew 5 7
Hebrew 5 7 it says that before Jesus was
crucified he prayed to God and God heard
him meaning that he saved him in the
stand even there's other scriptures
which is all scriptures he mentioned
some of them yes Jesus was not crucified
you understand what you have to
understand
before God you believe Jesus was God
before yeah
so he was God and then he became a baby
yeah so the baby
foreign
[Laughter]
of nothing
everyone is in need of God God does not
need nothing
you know before we go to his son when he
became a baby he went and got his nature
because he men are not God and God's Not
a Human so if you become a baby so that
baby firstly his mother is bigger than
him God Is Bigger Than everything
also he was in need of his mother's milk
God is not in need of food that's what
doesn't make any sense
no you mix it there's two things about
God there's what God does
and what God is God does whatever he
wishes according to his wisdom
for example you can slap yourself you
can I can stop myself but I will not do
it you know why because it doesn't mean
because I can I can do it I should do it
otherwise people think I'm still
perfect nature meaning God does not
become imperfect you understand if God
becomes imperfect that is not the same
God who is perfect all the time
that's what I'm saying by definition
when you come to Islam look at Allah
describe yourself Allah
yeah
okay but but even if Jesus
that's my point doesn't make any sense
because Lord okay before Jesus people
understood God everything about God but
God understand them too God doesn't have
to become a rat or a chicken to
understand us God understand us better
than ourselves
yeah he knows everything about us school
doesn't have to become a dog to
understand dogs God doesn't have to
become rats
his faith
who are the best people to be our role
model good
um
nothing is equal to God
why would I
whatever you talk to me
show himself
whatever you say from God is bad
yeah it's bad yeah it's fair because
whatever
you can understand it that's perfect but
there is where there's wisdom behind it
whatever God does because God is the
most just
you understand we could create a baby
handicapped or with a disease that is
fairness there doesn't mean because you
don't know it no there is because God
does not explain to us every time we
create someone handicapped or with
disease just tell you why no understand
but we know God has the perfect absolute
wisdom you understand yeah God knows the
best
human being that's it you know
that's now you understand to go back to
the main points
but
I know it's good because doesn't mean
because I don't understand it because
what is fairness and firmness Injustice
when you put something or you give
something uh someone that he does not
deserve but whatever God gave and
created that thing deserves it we're
going to create the baby he deserves it
doesn't mean we say he deserves it I
mean he's an evil baby no that's why
people think they think ah he deserves
because evil no that is a test for the
truth for the family if they be patient
you know God will reward them but to go
back to main points the main point here
is we need to take Christianity the
foundation of Christianity doesn't make
any sense like for example you said God
wants to be our role model
boat is perfect
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's why God's wisdom he chose people
amongst us to teach us how to live our
life and to follow them understand
I'm just talking about you saying God
came down as the following that doesn't
make any sense because if God become a
baby baby are in need of food God is not
in need of food there's this quote this
call always again paradox paradox what
is it you say someone is perfect and
imperfect at the same time it doesn't
make any sense but I say to you also
okay is it possible for God to be
imperfect
is it possible for God to be imperfect
if you become impactful he cannot be
good anymore
if God is imperfect he cannot be God
because God is perfect all the time
yeah he wouldn't do that no no in
Bedford no no but if it's perfect all
the time it's not about Cancer Cannot
because God becoming imperfect and
imperfect something does not exist in a
reality it's a paradox it's just you
play with words yeah because it makes
any sense
our discussion is about God you know
what if you notice I'm defending God I'm
defending God to be imperfect you won't
go to the impact that doesn't make any
sense
your friend everybody said it's possible
for God to become Imperfects
questions
it's such a pain that he actually you
know he has every pain for myself
so so Jesus died for Hitler
foreign
the killing of innocent people by saying
to the murderer Jesus died for your sins
justifying your own sins
so so now so now everyone can so yeah
would you still love them okay I will
love him no doubt about that but I will
correct him it's our Partnership if he's
doing something let me give you an
example imagine we have three people
listen to this imagine have two sons you
have two sons yeah one of them break
TV
so to forgive the one who breaks TV you
punish the innocent one is that just
that thing
okay imagine you have two sons yeah one
of the sun he breaks the TV another
television the brexit yeah so for you to
forgive the son who breaks the team
television you go and punish the
innocent son
is that fair it's not fair so okay Jesus
he never commit no Jesus never commit
any crimes so what God is doing instead
of punishing the criminals he's
punishing the innocent one Are we more
fair than God
you see
in the summer points
okay again is is it just for God to
punish Jesus who is innocent person
he'll never commit no rape no mercy
people because he has loved ones so he
has a love he died for the murderous and
the rapist and for petrified
not like I do uh
it's not nice oh no it's nice for Madras
it's not nice yeah I mean nothing is so
happy with that you know what you're
doing on the camera you're telling
murderers go kill people because Jesus
you're making the righteous and the evil
do is the same same that's what you're
doing it they're all the same according
to them
beautiful
you want to talk about Jesus on God
that's it it's okay
no no you know what this is
yeah
but okay okay
imagine someone says to you
I need a commit crime I have a common
crime here yes so this is that's my sins
do you say yes
no no no no okay so now what are you
doing you are encouraging people to go
commit crimes because Jesus died for
them so now someone who's a rapist he's
gonna say you know what I love raping
women I'm gonna have to walk because
Jesus died for my sins Jesus faith of my
sins you know what is this teaching you
go against the Old Testament
[Music]
and if you do good deeds it will be hard
for you so in the Old Testament teaches
you that if you do crime you'll be
responsible for it so Jeremiah Daniel
Moses all of them came with the same
teacher according to you Christian Jesus
came with it's okay I'll die for your
sins do whatever you want to do guess
who came after Prophet Muhammad who said
if you commit crime you'll be Angus yes
Allah forgive you if you turn away from
it and your offense so to be honest
logically speaking now the false prophet
is Jesus according to Christians and the
true one is Muhammad because Muhammad is
teaching he goes in line with Moses
Jeremiah Daniel and the other prophets
of messenger
yeah thank you very much but let me show
you that passage can I show you the
passage
you can
he's like you Ezekiel 18 18.
you don't have your Bible
see we're Muslims I have not even my
phone yet
leader
[Music]
is clear man
420. okay
we did to see my points here is that the
the Old Testament doesn't teach you
people should die for yourself
yeah of course everybody is responsible
for their own lives but everybody
um
a wicked person turns away from all the
sins
they have committed and keeps all my
decrees and does what is just and right
the person will surely live they will
not die no one of the offenses they have
committed will be remembered against
them because of the righteous things
they have done they will live so here
clearly teaches us if you commit a crime
no one should die for you right so with
the Old Testament as a teaching parents
no it's God it's not good so it's good
with God if you do crack and just go
your father should not be responsible
for your crime yeah no one else I said
no one no one no one your father anyone
else that's my point you know you know
like I said to you this teaching of
Jesus died for your sins that's what
caused the Europeans to come and enslave
the Africans because that will sit and
we're gonna save you we're gonna do this
that's what the Bible was used to
enslave the people in the stand so you
have to understand look when it comes to
Islam simple one god is perfect he chose
Moses Abraham Noah Jacob Isaac Prophet
Muhammad to come to teach us how to
worship God alone I'll show you his
Isaiah 42 Isaiah 42
awesome
I'll show you either Isaiah 42.
you can read it and then go you can no
this is the last one We're not gonna
hold you inshallah thank you for giving
us your time
appreciate it
servants
the servants
yeah myself
My Chosen One in Hong Kai the light I
will put my spirit on him he will bring
Justice to the Nations another one is
John's house watch this there's many you
can go back with it let the witnesses
no no no no not the name description
because Jesus name is not in the Old
Testament there is no Jesus in the Old
Testament at all the names yeah so here
I watched it
I'll show you let the witness and his
town raises their wings let the
settlement worked up
foreign
all right
the Bible today
just listens into the order of their
best
then who
a
so when you go Genesis 14 42 cleanly
speaking about someone whose God is
going to set to the Giant's house yes if
you go to King James and that Prophet is
coming from the the kedar and clearly
there was no Prophet came from the
leadership except Prophet Muhammad
I mean because you have to go I can
explain to you
prophecies that he said he said it will
come a time when you see Barefoot Arab
man compete in business
let me ask you where is the tallest
building in the world
the tallest the tallest world is the
tallest building
where is the tallest building now
in Dubai yeah
Burj Khalifa is the tallest building
Burj Khalifa is in Dubai which is the
Arab Venezuela Prophet Muhammad as that
will happen and we can see it right now
there's many provinces for example
Prophet Muhammad said you will come a
time Allah it will come a time will you
see a woman dressed but naked at the
same time dressed but and naked at the
same time go outside see a woman just
know you know forgot Muhammad told us in
the Quran says Allah mentioned that
Satan Lucifer Satan the devil will
inspire people to change Allah's
creation so Allah creative as a man they
will change to become a woman as a woman
this was happening now in the Quran 1400
years ago so how he knew that
listen I don't I don't reject everything
from the Bible I believe there's some
truth in it however I believe the Roman
pagans mixed up the truth with the
fossils like the sun god he came again
Constantine he used to worship the sun
him and his father Constantine and Paul
Paul he was not even there's many
articles many books written holy was not
a learned a Jewish man it was not from
the Pharisees it's just a lie before he
changed the teacher of Jesus anyway
[Music]
it would be a great
conversation
um I don't know what's his name is
how can I speak to him then
Instagram
do you have a pen you can operate fast
um
I know one word in Germany but I cannot
say to you
I know when we're there
okay
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so what's the next day listen
foreign
[Laughter]
that's that was sorry the right is very
bad
no no
Noah
my name is
Chelsea I don't know how you write okay
okay
thank you very much
advise you to live with when you go home
raise your hand to the god of Abraham
you're good at Moses the god of Jesus to
guide you
you are